aujourd'hui on réussit cette caméra à
360 de samsung dans un lieu un petit peu
spécial un petit peu en altitude et
surtout dans un lieu qui est vraiment
adapté pour la 360 tu vas voir en
prendre plein la gueule
[Musique]
puis du paris ou 2 km 5 bombes allons-y
regarde l'autre côté stand de tir danger
défense d'entrée
[Musique]
comme brian waters brian
c'est à garder une dernière vidéo tu
sais que j'ai acheté la dernière samsung
gallagher samsung jir 360 la nouvelle
caméra effectivement qu'il parlait de
faire du 360° et je me suis dit rien de
tel pour l'essayer kayes dans un coin un
petit peu sympa avec une du cool donc
d'où l'idée de venir ici en haut du
puits du paris ou dans le puy-de-dôme
derrière tu as un très joli cratère dans
lequel on va aller se mettre pour
effectivement parler de cette caméra des
points positifs comme des points
négatifs regarde de l'autre côté
[Musique]
prudence marche aux taxes et des
conseillers bonbons y aller alors
ah oui
[Musique]
escalade
alors quoi de mieux pour faire une vidéo
à 360 degrés que de se poser au centre
d'un endroit qui est vraiment dédié pour
ça là on est au centre d'un cratère dans
le puits du par exemple y dom et tu vois
c'est au regard d'un de tous les côtés
on est vraiment pile poil dans le truc
le plus adapté pour faire de la vidéo à
360 degrés
maintenant le seul bémol que j'ai c'est
le vent il ya un petit peu de vent et je
crois malheureusement que si je veux te
parler tranquillement et prendre un
petit peu de temps pour parler de teck
et de high tech et j'ai peur que si le
vent se lève
ça va rapidement être la mère sont
toutes là aujourd'hui je veux vraiment
faire un débrief pour parler de cette
caméra
la samsung jr 360 que j'essayais depuis
quelques jours alors il ya des choses
très très bien que cette caméra et il ya
d'autres choses qui sont beaucoup moins
bien donc on va prendre le temps d'en
parler je pense qu'on va redescendre un
peu plus bas c'est un peu plus abritée
comme ça on sera la nation car tu es mon
fils vraiment le spot est incroyable
fait le tour nourry toi parce que on
n'est pas souvent au centre en un volcan
et je crois même que ce doit être un
dessin youtuber français qui fait de la
tête qui a déjà fait une vidéo au centre
d'un volcan qui fait un peu
[Musique]
de côté sa garde
prière de ne pas déranger propos
attention des carrefours comme je te
disais j'ai fait l'acquisition il n'y a
pas longtemps de cette fameuse samsung
gear 360 la caméra de samsung qui est en
somme relativement sympa cette version
2010 est se tient directement points ce
qui change avec la version 2016 que tu
pouvais posé avec qui tu es sur l'espèce
de trépied et que tu pouvais attaché
imposé facilement sur un pied sur une
perche tout en sachant tout en sachant
que celle-ci effectivement tu peux aussi
la poser sur une perche
parce que tu as un pas de vis en tout
donc tu peux complètement le faire
d'ailleurs la toute première vidéo que
j'ai fait en 360 je les poser sur un
pied ce qui était relativement pratique
alors il ya vraiment des points super
positif avec ses deux caméras
moi je n'avais jamais essayé un devis de
deux caméras à 360 je trouve que le
concept est génial
maintenant il ya des points quand même
relativement négatifs à commencer par la
qualité
donc comme je te disais cette caméra est
là des points positifs et des points
négatifs à toute première chose c'est
comment naviguer dans la vidéo en 360 je
ne sais pas si tu as déjà utilisé des
vidéos 160 alors si tu es sur ton
téléphone m'attaque à naviguer en
bougeant droite à gauche 2 août en bas
ça marche très bien si on tue scroll sur
le côté avec ton doigt et tu verras que
ça fait bouger aussi de la caméra et ça
marche super bien si tu es sur ton
ordinateur je te conseille d'utiliser
chrome navigateur chrome de google qui
marche très bien qu'il permet
effectivement de déplacer la souris
directement sur la vidéo cette caméra
elle est super sauf en faible luminosité
faible luminosité forcément ça va
rajouter du grain c'est pas terrible
mais normalement avec une journée comme
celle là avec le temps qui fait c'est
très sympa et tu peux vraiment profité
alors le gros problème qu'on a sur ce
truc les deux gros problèmes qu'ont à
mon avis dans cette caméra le premier se
situe au film en full hd 1920 par 1080
le problème c'est que comme ta vidéo ça
d'espèces de cercle arrondi parce que ce
sont deux fiches que tu as de chaque
côté
ça va les étirer pour en faire des
rectangles ans et de pouvoir les
utiliser dans ta dans son logiciel
d'édition ou lorsque vous envoie
directement sur réseaux sociaux ça
marche aussi comme ça le gros problème
que tu vas rencontrer comme ça si tu
veux c'est que quand tu vas être en 1920
par 1080 tu vas zoom et un petit peu
dedans pour avoir un point de vue
centrale et pouvoir se déplacer dans ce
qui fait que tu vas être en réalité
pixelisé enfin pas pixelisé tu vas
vraiment perdre en qualité sans
forcément de parler de pixels mais tu
vas perdre en qualité
et ça c'est vraiment dommage parce qu'en
fait la sourde et des caméras qui ont
quand même ce type de qualité c'est
quand même con alors ce qu'il faut faire
c'est filmé en 4k maintenant derrière il
faut un ordinateur qui puisse pédaler
suffisamment pour les quatre cas tous
les écrans ne sont pas en cas de cas
même si son point 4 44% quand même une
netteté parce que tu rentreras plus tu
te retrouveras plus situent sur des
résolutions tu vas avoir un effet de
zoom tu vas perdre de la qualité moment
tu va naviguer dans ta vidéo tu perdrais
pas du tout de qualité donc mieux votre
sur des résolutions très très hot
pour pouvoir utiliser ce type de
technologie c'est ce qu'il faut donc se
mettre en quatre cas c'est la priorité
le gros problème qui sait que ce petit
outil la centrale utilise tout de suite
et je peux soir récupérer ma vidéo sur
une carte sd card dans il à mettre sur
mon ordinateur auquel cas je dois
utiliser un logiciel qui me permet de
faire ce qu'on appelle un stich c'est à
dire de mettre ma vidéo qui en format
rond en format rectangulaire mais ça
pour le faire il faut que je puisse la
porte et moi j'ai final cut pro x n'y a
que le pro ça ne marche pas il faut que
je passe un stich d'abord oujda
convertissent ensuite que je puisse la
mettre dedans fin c'est très très
compliqué je crois que soit deux
premiers il n'y a pas ce problème sinon
je peux l'envoyer directement de mon de
ma caméra à mon téléphone
le problème c'est que tu effectivement
une application aujourd'hui qu'ils
étaient développées pour un os je laisse
aussi si tu veux c'est qu'il ya un bug
en tout cas j'ai eu un mois j'ai
rencontré un bug quand je vais envoyer
des vidéos en full hd directement
sur mon téléphone ça marche par contre
des quais de la 4k depuis à 99% ça
plante l'api plantes et je peux plus
rien faire et franchement c'est la merde
je suis dégoûté du coup je le fais sur
un samsung j'utilisais le samsung de
justin justin qu'elle accompagne si tu
ne sais pas et voilà ça marche nickel
n'y a pas de problème donc du coup je
vais utiliser un samsung à part pour
pouvoir le faire ensuite rapatrier
directement sur mon mac enfin c'est un
bordel sans nom
il ya peut-être un bug a corrigé
j'espère qu'il sera corrigé parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est vraiment pas
confort autre truc qui est chiant sur
cette application sur iphone c'est que
tu n'as pas l'option pour pouvoir avoir
les live facebook et youtube alors que
c'est vraiment un point fort cette
caméra et s'est vendue comme ça en
disant tu peux maintenant faire des
lives en cas de cas sur youtube et sur
facebook sauf que là c'est pas du tout
possible c'est possible sur l'appli
samsung je les ai vus tu as le bouton il
existe et les lie dans le menu principal
était connecté à ton smartphone sur ios
c'est mort ça n'existe pas une fois de
plus j'espère que ron mise à jour et que
sa conscience dans les temps à venir
parce que ça c'est quand même content un
produit en mettant en avant cette
fonctionnalité et ne pas voir dans
l'application c'est vraiment dommage
autre point un peu négatif cette caméra
on peut pas branché de micros en plus
même un micron bluetooth connaissant ça
n'existe pas il y en a pas là dessus en
tout cas peut pas le brancher dont tu te
retrouves forcément avec les petits
micros intégrés
alors forcément c'est avait un micro à
part trois peut-être un bout de câble
qui dépassait ça serait pas terrible
mais en terme de qualité audio tu perds
vraiment parce que la dcri un peu de
vent il n'y a pas moyen de calfeutrer
les micros pour pas avoir de vent alors
il même si je vais coller un petit bout
de deux mômes août dessus ça va ça va se
voir à la vidéo ça va être dégueulasse
sinon sur le principe je possède caméra
est vraiment super je trouve que le
principe effectivement de pouvoir avoir
du 360 pouvoir mettre les lunettes
verres j'essayais l'immersion l'étape dé
leur côté une qualité à la base qui est
bien et qu'on plus incertain du débit
donc soit de l'awb delà de la bonne 4g
ou alors de la fibre en adsl c'est bien
mais des fois ça rame un peu et c'est
pénible dès que tu as une top définition
des près de la bande passante derrière
c'est un vrai délice tu t'éclates tu
peux vraiment profiter maintenant le
point encore négatif c'est dès que tu le
fais dans les lunettes
r tu va poser sur un casque tu vois un
petit peu le pixel de l'écran c'est
dommage donc avoir plus tard ce que ça
donnera sur les casquettes type oculus
trift qui sont vraiment d'une excellente
qualité est là où effectivement d'un on
perdra pas en qualité en immersion en
ayant ces cas ce que la sur le visage ça
ça peut être vraiment top
sinon pour déplacer naviguer est
vraiment en immersion dans la vidéo être
avec dans l'ue lieu tu vois ici le lieu
par exemple qu'il est juste top c'est le
printemps on a le soleil qui est super
cool en face les petits oiseaux derrière
on est au calme
vraiment c'est génial donc le concept
est génial à mon avis la 360 l'immersion
la réalité augmentée la réalité
virtuelle j'invente rien mais ça va
vraiment être l'avenir de tous qu'on va
retrouver sur internet dans les temps à
venir aujourd'hui on est au début des
technologies même si elles sont quand
même relativement avancé ça va aller
beaucoup plus loin ça n'augmente est
vraiment qualité il va pouvoir faire
vraiment vraiment vraiment se faire
plaisir et ça c'est génial
[Musique]
tu faire des vidéos à 360 je te ferai
une vidéo prochainement pour t'expliquer
un petit peu les différentes techniques
et astuces pour pas galéré parce que moi
j'ai perdu quand même une grosse grosse
journée a galéré à essayer de voir
comment ça marche et quand tu as un ordi
qui pas très récent quand après samsung
surtout quand à la samsung ça marche
tout seul mais quand un hack et quant à
final cut pro
ouah c'est la galère donc je te ferai
une vidéo très très prochainement pour
t'expliquer un petit peu comment ça
marche
évitez le parcours du combattant que
j'ai pu connaître pas trop galérer même
au niveau technique parce que il ya
différentes types de vidéos qui existe
il ya différents formats ensuite pour
exporter pour envoyer sur youtube mais
il faut faire une injection de métadatas
enfin je t'expliquerai tout ça mais tu
verras
j'espère que ce sera gagné un petit peu
de temps
[Musique]